go ahead what's your name darling Manari
al-rahman and actually a social media
manager too
so what would you say about house I know
you were talking about Pinterest yeah
houses very construction and building
material specific yep and I actually
think that if I were to pick well I mean
I would probably do both yeah what would
you think about house and sponsored post
there because they look very organic
when you say house house house calm I
just went through got a second round of
funding got it you know I haven't dug
deep into them you know and so I'm I I
can't speak to it but I I think the
point since I don't know much about
house that you made is the important one
which is you know that whole little rant
I just sended with with the 25 percent
of dumb [ __ ] and you said I'll probably
do both I can't wrap my head around it
being the middle of 2014 and people not
allocating three to seven percent of
their monies and times into trying
Instagram house Facebook it doesn't make
sense
experimental budget right here you're
better off figuring out it doesn't work
for you because then it eliminates your
time of thinking about it
versus just deciding I don't get it
we're not gonna do it yeah alright and
then my other question is with with the
Facebook dark posts are you talking
about sponsored post no so sponsor post
where she's going for all of you know is
you post something on your fan page and
then you see that little thing on the
right side it's a sponsored if you play
with Facebook a little bit and then it
allows you to open up and you can target
Friends of the page friends of friends
of the page or cred I'm not there's a
page editor on the backend of Facebook
and it looks more like Google AdWords
you go in there you create your content
and then you target whatever the hell
you want has nothing to do with your
page you want to target recent college
grads that are moved like if you're in
the rental space and we're killing it in
the rental space right now because we're
just targeting people that are
graduating college in June right now and
have shown online behavior to searching
around New York so we know they're
coming to move to New York and we're
just putting out and add this is rent
here they're actually looking there and
we're converting at a ludicrous
conversion rate things that SEO and SEM
and all this other stuff we've done for
years
even coming close to because attention
they're actually looking in their phone
and in their feet they're actually
seeing it not like your your ad and
we're magazine page 97 but that's listen
that's how I believe like I'm not trying
to make fun of we're print what you're
gonna go to page 9 that newspaper right
there what that person spent fifteen
thousand dollars on page a8 you guys are
gonna see that maybe but you're paying
eight times that print the way we pay
for print is we pay eight times the
circulation of a newspaper in case all
eight of them get to page 32 bottom left
corner and see our Lexus ad it's
ludicrous its fantasy world that's mm
it's 1994 it's 1986 it's [ __ ] 2014
sorry yes sir
Gary I was really impressed with you two
years ago I went out and bought your
book thank you
I'm having a little hard time wrapping
myself around something you said today
please and the example worked for you
yes but there are many of us who really
need to reach high-level decision makers
I agree which is why not necessarily the
CEOs of the top 25 fortune 100 companies
yep
but in our industry please we need to
reach the right person give me an
example of a right person by the way
this is why I do Q&A because I can sit
up here and say this is great this is
like this right here this moment is
about to be the best [ __ ] part of
this whole talk so give me give me give
me the right person the five the five
treasurers or marketing directors of the
five top solar installers in whatever
market you're in
love it so real quick let's jump into
this I guarantee of those five people
four of them have a LinkedIn account I
guarantee it right correct good and you
know the name of these companies and you
know their titles you just gave them to
me so LinkedIn right now and probably
release to everybody in the next six
months two things you can do
in six months you'll be able to go to
LinkedIn and do the same thing that you
can do on Facebook dark posts on
LinkedIn so you'll be able to create a
piece of content now you have to decide
if that's a picture if that's an
infographic
if it's a white paper you've got it if
it's a nice picture of you you've got to
decide but you'll be able to create a
post that those five people will see
when they log into LinkedIn in their
feed and I'm in that beta and I'm
testing it and it's working in credit
and we're targeting CFO's controllers
these kind of people the thing you can
do right now is take those people's
names and do the version that I did with
Twitter and Facebook and targeting them
in that world so that's the tactical
execution of reaching that person the
part that I'm having a hard time
grasping please is I just don't believe
that they are on social media as their
children are I don't trust that LinkedIn
yes I trust okay so um I'm hungry for
what's gonna around the corner yep but I
don't trust that CEO that I yep totally
different example I want to reach the
president chairman wells-fargo
okay this is I cannot believe this is a
man who's looking at LinkedIn I don't
believe this is a man who's spending his
time on social media listen to things
one great believe what you want to
believe to you may be 100 percent
correct three I'm thrilled with the
thesis of these executions may not work
for your target audience I'm not sure
how you plan on targeting the Wells
Fargo CEO versus social media I'm sure
there's some theory you have right you
know by an ad in The Wall Street Journal
because you think he's reading it that's
not gonna work right so here's what I
can tell you and this is the real kicker
of this story one I get it I get what
your thesis is I hear it every day nine
hundred times a day let me tell you
about something we did recently that
completely will blow your mind we had a
client who said the same thing we're
trying to reach it's a it's a hedge fund
play think about how what kind of net
worth individuals you need and the guy
says to me Gary I think you're the bad
you clearly helped the business that
you're working on that I invested in
this is why we're sitting together I got
to him because we're crushing it for one
of his businesses he goes but you can't
figure this out right because these 80
year old guys 6-0 guys they're not on
this I go okay if you believe that we
did the link thing thing in real time he
was blown away by how many of them were
on Facebook and Twitter here's my real
question these five people have you put
their name in with Twitter and Facebook
into Google to see if they are or aren't
I'm just I'm curious no no I just gave
that to you as an example so one you
should do that okay because you might
get surprised but even if they're not
here's the tactic we took and we've
converted our first person you said the
most important thing my friend you said
I don't believe they are but their
children are right
we've just converted our first 10
million dollar check to this fund by
knowing who the individual was and by
making content for his children that we
thought they would show to him we made
we we made a piece of content that was
worth the price of admission you can
stop right there and I'll give you
another example we just started working
with a retirement home and we're
targeting you know 50 to 70 year olds
who are putting their parents into the
home everybody doesn't think 50 to 70 or
the fastest growing sector in Facebook
is 50 to 70 year olds and they're sticky
right once they're there they're there
and they're like for anybody here who's
got who's in that range or has a parent
in that range you know that once your
parent gets into that world
they're just bothering the [ __ ] out of
you this Facebook thing is incredible
I'm telling you mom alright last
question I see him at double zero Gary
I'm getting ready to have breakfast with
an executive for twitter he'll be
writing you an endorsement it's cool
this industry is one where approximately
85% are searching for their new home
online everyone heard that statistic
only 40 percent according burrell of
developers and home builders even spend
their money online yeah no I know all
that okay and then there's another
percentage 1% of expected sales should
be spent on marketing yep so there's one
before trillion-dollar home industry
yeah I mean there's one point four
trillion dollars in new homes sold every
year one percent at 14 billion no one
right yeah you're pretty I'm so pissed
off about this data because I've looked
at it yes it's that if you [ __ ] don't
move soon I'm coming into this visit
putting you out of business so here but
here here here's what here your our
disruptor which makes your methodology
great but these guys are trying to do it
themselves yeah okay and the challenge
with these engineering constructive
construction finance mines cuz I deal
with all of them and I was an ex-banker
now yeah knowledge is yeah is what's the
metric so right we used to be under cost
per lead yeah cost per lead cost per
lead trulia zillow yom-yom source code
for lead well with our CRM we tracked be
back so we don't just see where the
buyer source from what their lead source
was cost per lead but what's there be
back what where do they come back to
your content of course right
that's how marketing work right so Smart
Touch is about the 52 touch points it
takes over two hundred ninety days to
reel in a buyer okay but we can't
convince this industry to hire vendors
to do it for them because they're not
they're not having they're not measuring
the ROI they're having a hard time
saying okay if I invest in your digital
media agency your social agency yep
they'll hire vendors to do their seat
want rock in their foundations and
project I mean they're developers I know
they have no staff they're one guy a
finance team and they're all their
vendors yep yet they're still trying to
hire one person in-house to do it
themselves
uh-huh and I think it's because they
can't get their head around the metrics
yep how do I get an ROI out of social
media can you up talk about that for a
second the only two piece of advice I
have for you are this one the biggest
way I've been able to win the ROI
conversation is by auditing the ROI of
everything else they do right so they've
made the mental commitment to running an
ad in the local newspaper the local
magazine or outdoor media or calling or
direct mail or and then I just asked
them what's the ROI and the truth is you
know nobody's got good CRMs they don't
know they've just accepted it they've
made the decision that this hasn't all
why because we've been doing it for 80
years that's number one number two I'll
be very honest with you and this is now
for you and your business because I
notice how you set it up
I have spent 0 minutes 0 seconds 0 hours
0 days weeks months years trying to
convince somebody to use me or my
company there is enough people that are
at least somewhat interested the notion
that I'm gonna convince somebody or
spend my time and effort in 2014 to make
them commence to use this stuff and do
this stuff I have no time for that
person 0 spend all your time being on
the offense not the defense the defense
is meeting somebody who's a big get and
they don't get it they don't care I mean
I met with Albertsons had a real long
conversation their CEO could care less
and I don't give a [ __ ] right because I
just move on to the next there is no
follow-up
there is no knock again in two weeks
there's no hit me up in six months I
just look at that dude and go good when
Amazon puts you out of [ __ ] business
I'm gonna laugh in your [ __ ] face
I'll leave with that thank you